us good evening and welcome and good
evening to our members of public i just
want to do the uh emergency evacuation
before we actually start the full
meeting okay
so
should you be required should
stay at
all right all right
all right
are you all right
right good should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building via the entry doors
to the hall continue straight on go
through the two sets of double doors on
the right hand side to the car park
which is the assembly point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
members when i invite you to speak
please wait until there's a microphone
in front of you before speaking as
microphones are needed for the hearing
loop
and for the audio recording
these are all switched on ready for you
to speak so you do not need to adjust
them please make sure the microphone is
in directly in front of you before
speaking
members voting will be done on the show
of hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands
for and then against recommendations and
we'll also ask for a show of hands for
those wishing to abstain from voting
members before we start
i'd like to introduce you in case none
of you have met him uh
bill drain or philip drain
right okay phil drain he's the new
director of place
so welcome to your first meeting
thank you
are we all
yeah
members apologies for absence
this counselor
i was indicating because i've only just
been given one of the items i'd like
time to read it
right has everyone else had
counselor bob milne
oh jeez ramses
from councillor jack lorman chuck norman
thank you
can i just go through the um
apologies for absence um so that's chuck
norman
um
who else have we got we've got um
ian foster and the substitute member is
councillor dave sparing
who else we got can't think
yeah counselor butcher and counselor
[Music]
constable
right okay
um yeah i've got jack norman thank you
right if i can i
um
so you haven't read one of your papers
mrs mason
right okay
that's it this evening right okay can i
give i'll stop this meeting for five
minutes and give you five minutes to
read it is that okay
i hope so
right members we'll stop this meeting
for five minutes so everyone can make
sure they've read their papers
and they're all aware of what's
happening
thank you
substitute
members we have no non-members attending
a journal item gender four minutes of
the meeting held on the 21st of
june 2022 are they agree members
thank you
agenda five to receive declarations of
interest are there any please
if not through the meeting if you
oh sorry sorry councillor williams
there are a non-binary interest
in as much that i have known to the
applicant
um
i have taken advice i shall be voting on
this application thank you thank you
very much cancer williams that's noted
item six
is the
6365 spa road hockley
this has uh was a deferred item and it's
my strengths
you'll be leading on this
thank you very much
this application as members will recall
was deferred at the meeting of the 24th
of may for the submission of a
construction method statement members
had raised in that debate a number of
issues around the safety and site
operations if permission were granted
because of the limited
size of the site and the absence of
pavement for pedestrians because the
site has to be cross pavement served um
as we can see the site outlined here in
the center of the screen is just uh to
the sort of west of station
approach um and it's a
single-storey building that is currently
an estate agent you can see there that
there's a land to the side within the
plot that the estate agents currently
use for some uh off-street parking if we
could just remind members please of the
existing elevations please plan two
just to recap
the building is fairly non-descript a
small single-story flat roof building
and if we could look at the site plan
that's existing please
you'll see the space to the side where
the uh car parking currently is um if we
could jump to for the perspective thank
you the proposal before you coming back
tonight
is for who to demolish the existing
building
and in its place construct this building
here three stories in parts and two
stories
um to the left-hand side as you would
look at it
it contains four flats two two-bedroom
and two one-bedroom flats and if we can
look at plan five please members will
recall that at ground floor there was a
provision of these two parking spaces
and whilst we're on this plan members
last time
expressed concern that the
difficulty there may be in operating
this site because of this build out
return
if we could look at plan six please
the applicant in hearing the debate
although it wasn't specifically minuted
but listening to members concerns has
altered the design to create a circular
pillar here giving more room so that the
vehicles can enter and leave you see
with this swept path movement
successfully hopefully overcoming uh
members concerned
concerns sorry if we can see just the
elevation for completeness that the
detail is fairly minor it introduces a
small column detail there that the
applicant has usefully
circled for you the main
details that needed to be covered was
the construction methodology and the
applicant has addressed this in two ways
by firstly submitting a
traffic management plan which is set out
for you on page 6.2 paragraphs d2 to d12
and i think this addresses most of the
concerns members had about the
activities and the day-to-day management
of it
you'll see that deliveries are
pre-arranged with a 20-minute uh prior
to delivery uh notification to the site
and at d10 members will see that
the deliveries would be between eight
and five
and eight and one on a saturday
but you'll see over the page on the
actual activities on the site the
working hours are obviously an hour
later to
um
six o'clock in the weekday because
obviously the site workers would be
clearing up after the deliveries so to
avoid any confusion there the deliveries
would occur well within the working time
of the
site operatives
the
members will see that the matters
are expressed there there is some
generality with these statements that
occur
uh the standardized
approach with the london boroughs and
things it's an activity that they
undertake through site management
insurance risk
i understand members concerns where
there are issues of practicality raised
by men by the public and i can see where
members are going
i have to advise you that essentially
these kind of details about how wide
scaffold balls are and
the stop go provisions for the guys
managing traffic where they have to
narrow the road if only through during
deliveries they're essentially not
material planning considerations if
you're looking at planning conditions
you're really looking to say well this
scheme is unacceptable
but is there a condition that will make
a difference that makes it acceptable
that the routine management of
implementation of a scheme is not the
same as if you had say a factory
somewhere that was perhaps very close to
residential properties and then the
activity in that factory you might think
is acceptable
if the hours for some reason were
curtailed to stop say 24-hour working or
something like that the activities of
implementation
are down on site to their health and
safety executive for the protection of
workers and other agencies but not not
the planning function to enforce uh on a
practical day-to-day basis so although
we've had the details the applicant i
hope has given members some comfort to
the uh situation on how the site will
operate
the recommendation is approval to the
conditions that were previously
recommended to you and which is set out
in the report
thank you
we have one uh speaker on there public
speaker and it's miss mary power the
planning agent and
you know where to sit
and again you've got five minutes and
we'll allow you let you know when
there's one minute to go thank you
good evening members and thank you again
for the opportunity to speak
we had the benefit of listening to
members concerns raised at the last
committee
we noted those as a vehicle maneuvers in
and out of the site from the two parking
spaces
disturbance and safety issues during
construction particularly for
pedestrians and children walking to and
from school
buildability and deliveries to address
each one the applicant has undertaken
the following
the applicant has redesigned the
building corner which the officer
mike has just presented to you to
increase the maneuverability of the
parking spaces through a circular brick
detail which we hope addresses that the
members concerns about that point
the applicant has also employed a
contract contractor sorry to prepare a
construction management plan and a
traffic management plan and submitted
these to the council
we set out the processes and controls
embedded into the construction process
for this site
whilst it is unusual to prepare a sam
and a traffic management plan
pre-planning permission
as a contractor has not necessarily been
appointed at this stage the applicant
has employees a professional contractor
to consider how the building can be
erected
it should be considered to be a live
document as it's not possible at this
early stage to consider all movements to
and from the site or all elements of the
construction process
that a lot of that depends on where
materials are sourced from how many how
much of those materials come to site
when they come to site and that really
can't be
fully estimated until planning
permission is granted and there's
certainty about the scheme going ahead
it therefore may need to be amended as
the contractor moves forward with the
construction new building and as each
phase progresses from demolition
construction of foundations services to
everything above ground and all the
materials needed to complete the
building it does set the benchmark for
good working practices however
including health and safety
nuisance mitigation such as dust control
hours of operation and community liaison
which will be very important here
it demonstrates just how many processes
a contractor must consider in preparing
for and undertaking construction works
the traffic management plan addresses
issues of deliveries but it would be a
car free construction site
so i.e no employees would be able to
park on site during construction they'll
be encouraged to use public transport
and public car parks
it's not been possible to be more
specifically about deliveries including
vehicle movements as that must follow as
i've just described
any site is capable of finding a
solution for construction and there are
many more highly constrained sites in
dense urban areas that reach the
solution for construction
it is often the objective to build as
quickly as possible to ensure that local
disturbance is kept to a minimum whilst
respecting the working hour restrictions
the more hurdles that are placed in the
way the longer the construction process
takes there is therefore careful balance
required
between appropriate restrictions to
ensure safety
and convenient passage for residents and
local people and controls that may
significantly extend the build period
the applicants trust they have
demonstrated their intent to manage the
construction stage appropriately and
with the site's restrictions in mind to
limit impact on local residents and
people that use the footpath to move
around the town and between schools
we trust that members will accept the
officer's recommendation and approve the
application with the construction
management plan and traffic management
plan submitted
thank you very much thank you very much
we have no visiting members
i'll ask um if any committee members
wish to speak and the wall council
is councillor agenese can't stray your
knees
you're there you've changed places
you've confused me um you'll have five
minutes to speak on this thank you okay
thank you chair
i accept that the
the um
applicant has uh tried to address some
of the issues here
but one of the things that i think that
we made very clear when we dis when we
discussed this last time
is one of the issues of delivery times
the delivery times that have been
put forward on the traffic management
plan
have taken no consideration of our
concerns
whatsoever
if you have children going past there on
their way to school and on their way
back from school
this is a high risk
so i would venture to suggest that the
uh traffic management plan
should be looking at nine o'clock till
two o'clock for delivery
that would be my suggestion
and i'm open to
suggestions which would match in well
with the school attendance times
if others have
any opinions on that
i've had extension extensive discussions
with officers
um over the
the unusual nature
of the the call-in on this one in that
normally we would not be looking to
consider
the
construction management plan
but
the reason being why i called this in is
because i consider being
the ward member for the area and knowing
the area really well
that this is a high risk construction
very high risk construction therefore it
does warrant
having that extra bit of
consideration
given to it
whereas i accept that
normally the traffic management plan the
construction management plan is
a consideration after planning
i think the risk that is involved during
the construction of this is so high that
i think it would be
rather remissivist not to acknowledge
that fact
i accept that the hsc would be involved
but the problem that we have there is
the hsc
will be reactive
i.e
if there is an accident they will get
involved
the difference is that what we're trying
to do here
is to make sure that those accidents
don't happen
and i would like to recommend the
there is a condition put on the
planning
approval for this site
that
delivery times are kept strictly between
nine o'clock and two o'clock it is
possible i am in the trade i do know
that is possible and i know that if
there is a good uh management structure
on site it won't cause any further
delays it just means that they've got to
be more organized so
that is my
my submission thank you very much
officers would you like to come back
[Music]
we're in some difficulty in how i i hear
what members are saying about the
special nature and the constraints of
the site
what's
is likely to limit it in that way
would constrain the development i think
you heard from the applicants to say
that you know that would prolong the
duration and in some ways increase the
risk but i appreciate what members are
trying to do
what we did with the bulwark hall site
where i think there was a similar issue
about traffic worries although it was
somewhat removed from hockley i think
there was an issue about the main road
we did
members did accept a condition to
restrict deliveries between the hours of
8 and 9 30 which was the school run
times i think it was less about kids
going along the pavement as they do in
this case to to particularly the
greenswood school
it was more about the clash with the
school runs of big vehicles attending
the site and there was a condition on
that application that members were happy
with where they said there to be no
deliveries between eight in the morning
and nine thirty in the morning and then
at the school turnout time between
fourteen thirty and fifteen thirty and
that was monday to friday but during
school time
so if there was a break like you have in
the summer now there's sort of six weeks
or so then that would open up for the
developers to proceed in the best of the
weather
um but that was something that
members did use as a benchmark as i say
on another site in in different
circumstances i confess but it's more
about the flow of traffic as opposed to
that the concerns members have on the
actual pavement outside of the site
um but so
it's for members really i think to
consider i just want to know
okay members uh
oh i've got quite a few
counts of crips please
the last meeting was deferred on the
basis of producing a management
plan my problem with this one is it
doesn't go far enough
um
i actually wrote to the officers
with a few headline
issues
which i think should form part of this
management plan um
yes deliveries are important cutting the
time the timing of them and the
amount of time they take is fine but
it's relatively small beer compared with
what else we'll be creating problems in
that road
when the utilities come to ins to
reconnect foul water storm water gas
water electric and power
they will almost certainly be making
connections in the pavement and in the
road
there will be barriers there will be
temporary traffic lights and single lane
running for them to do their work
because they won't be able to do that
work in 20 minutes
it's days at least
and they never get themselves organized
to do it in some pattern so they'll all
be coming and going
scaffolding is another issue
the foundations we've got to run a pipe
across the pavement to pump the concrete
we've got
muck lorry to take the excavation
material away across the pavement
all i'm saying is
the management plan is a good idea
it's only a written document and the
lady said earlier on that no builder has
been allocated yet that makes it even
more important
to have this document
to a certain level
included in the package probably as a
condition
so that this builder when he is coming
on board catches up with the importance
that we only deferred this item for the
construction method statement and i'm
not i don't know if you're aware that
that's all we can debate this on we
can't debate on anything else we can
i have to stop you there the only thing
we can debate and talk about
on this application
is
the construction method tape yep okay
okay so are you going to pump the
concrete in i am not a planner
don't treat me with content thank you
let me say my you can't no you can't
because everybody else does no
okay right
we have to go
with what we do what we've deferred on
and that's what we've got to this is
what the planning meetings do yeah okay
so councillor spurring then councillor
mrs mason
um
pursuing councillors comments about the
delivery times
we recently had a school involved in a
delivery scenario and they had a very
limited delivery period that was at its
weimarch school
and it boiled down to about four hours a
day
because it interrupted with the school
time so it can be done and it can be
made a lot shorter than it currently is
being projected thank you jim thank you
councilman mrs mason
point of clarification perhaps from our
legal officer who's here
um i wasn't at the previous meeting so
i wasn't aware that this had been
approved other than it wasn't approved
it was deferred deferred well i wasn't
aware that if an item was deferred it
could we could only then debate the
deferment
um so i would like some clarification
that before we go further because by
implication if that's the only thing
you're going to allow to talk about
then we have
approved it subject to that one item
now
usually deferral means come back and
we'll have a look at it and then we
approve the whole application or not so
could i ask the legal officer to clarify
that for me please
thank you chris
um
so my understanding was that yes you
could
potentially discuss other parts of the
application if they were relevant
obviously to
kind of the main material considerations
um obviously you'd want to touch on the
reason that it was deferred as well but
yeah i think to obviously a certain
extent within reason you could discuss
other reasons yeah thank you that was my
understanding right thank you in that
case madam chairman may i talk to the
application yeah uh first of all i don't
know if there's any other pictures but
my knowledge of the area would indicate
and i'm sure councillors or the officers
will correct me if i'm wrong that there
is no pavement on the other side of the
road so this is the only pavement
that school children and pedestrians
were to use could someone have i presume
you've got photographs on the other side
okay so in that case we're talking about
the only pavement from
the senior school to where most of the
children walk down from that way so
i can understand the concerns about the
safety risk of pedestrians
and the concern about the enforcement of
conditions
but having read this application
quite thoroughly actually over the
weekend
my concern was much more for the balkan
mass
particularly the height
particularly the fact that it doesn't
comply with our policies our policies
are very clear that any dormers on the
front of a building would not be flat
roofed
this has patently got flat roof dormers
on the top
i think the height is particularly of
concern and the bulk massive concern
the
the principle of residential development
i think in this area isn't of concern
but i think this particular application
is of concern and certainly i would be
inclined to refuse it that it's contrary
to our policies dm1 and cp1 which seek a
high standard of design and layout and i
think this fails on that
can't just stop you from running can we
have the pictures of the elevation so we
know what counselor
mrs mason's uh so we can all understand
chip chairman while doing that we're
trying to get a street view up to
clarify the pavement perhaps when we've
done that if we could then show the okay
i said we've got
um that's looking from the bridge back
towards the site is comes up the site on
our right hand side of the screen where
the cursor is
there's no pavement officers
on this side that's not pavement
that's
i don't know i was thinking about by the
um i did because i'm not knowing it
wasn't no there
is actually
okay thank you
thank you so
madam chairman
my inclination would be to move for
refusal
because of the balkan mass because of
the flat roof doors i mean they're quite
dominant there um and it's it's kind of
contrary to our policy unfortunately i
can't quote the policy because i don't
remember it but i'm sure one of our
officers can supply that
and also because of the um
the risk to pedestrians with it's so
close to the pavement where there's no
pavement opposite
so the two things
give me great concern i don't know if i
have a second
right we've got a second up for refusal
i don't need to
um
and have we got
just some advice on members on the
reason for refusal due to the
construction and the loss of the
footpath during construction
i don't actually think that you know we
could actually defend that as a reason
for refusal
my main concern of mass the height which
is out of keeping it says in the actual
report the maximum height of the
building is 9.5 whereas
adjacent buildings are a lot lower
the fact that it's not policy compliant
the fact that they design
our policy says quite clearly we seek a
high
level a high standard of design and
layout
and unfortunately i think this fails
so my move for refusal stands
because of the dominance balkan max and
the material
and the lack of policy compliance with
the donors
and councillors do you still second that
thank you
sorry councillors can i just clarify on
the design grounds
we look for what is the precedent within
the street scene so although our
guidance the sbd2 and essex design guide
does look for pitched roof dormers
within a street scene there is part of
it which we would look to as in what is
existing in the street this street isn't
particularly dominated by any dormers
there's
because of the town center there's more
the flat roof and lightroom single story
is a long spa road and then you have
more flattened schemes which haven't got
the dormers on we do have this property
next door where you can see the sloped
roof and although it isn't
flat like this scheme has put forward it
wouldn't appear as we would look for in
guidance which is traditionally pitched
roof
so i wouldn't
necessarily say there is a strong
precedent to try and
put forward the pitched roofs where
there is
one immediately next door which isn't
policy compliant
the the building next door that you're
referring to i take it you're talking to
the white property there
has a sloped roof it's not pitched
those roofs are neither sloped nor pitch
and they're dominantly flat and i'm not
talking about the essex design guys i'm
talking about our policy it's in our
policy i've looked it up before
unfortunately i can't quote the actual
policy yeah that's bd2 yeah so we're not
talking we're talking about our policy
and i would actually
disagree that this is in the town centre
and
i would say it's on the edge of the town
center it's by the railway station
admittedly but it is not
in the centre of town at all so
i don't think that you can take that as
a town building it is not it's on the
outskirts of the
main pedestrian area this outside the
shopping area i mean that that has been
a property that's been used i think as
an estate agent for some time
but it's never been so dominant
and i still think that that is the bulk
of mass and the height of that building
is out of keeping with the area
and that is my view
now obviously it's subjective to a
degree but i can't see when it's that
much higher and that much different from
our policy
that that is unreasonable
right then was if we're going to vote on
this we need
we've got councillor stanley council
spurring i think and council williams
but can't stanley
um i was going to ask whether the the
roof on the adjacent or the next door
building
is not a flat roof it's
if it was tiled it would be a tiled roof
although it is not tiled it's a
construction of
felt roof
but it could be tiled on the same
essence of
we have done this in the past with a
school
that it was a back road in the school
not a high road and it didn't have as
much traffic as that high road has got
so i just
want the committee to consider that it
is a main road and there is a lot of
traffic in that road and pedestrians up
and down not as though it was in the
back of fitzweinmark where it was a back
road i know it was busy for school
children but nevertheless that will be
much more busier i'd like to point that
out to the committee thank you thank you
very much council sparring thank you
to council reeves point that he raised
we i'm still have concerns about this
traffic management where it says site
delivery are 800 to 1700 i know we we've
heard from uh the representative of the
developer that you know the the
management plan has got to be put
forward but i think we should
comment that what has been indicated as
the new idea
i don't think is acceptable i don't
think it achieves what we're trying to
protect which is a number of children
going to a school
and their normal course of day where
they have no alternative
to to avoid this situation and i say we
have seen where another big school was
involved where it was limited to about
three and a half hours four hours a day
delivery time and it worked they played
the game and it worked fine so i don't
see why we can't you know try and be
tighter on this it can be done it just
needs organizing as as councillors
mentioned to them thank you thank you
council williams
i'm perturbed
sorry is that working
i'm going to perturb the reasons for
refusal um this came before the
committee
the last time and it was refused on the
grounds of
having a construction management plan
we're now moving the goal posts how long
do we carry on doing this every time it
comes back
i'm sorry mrs mitchell
but it needs to be clear it wasn't
refused
i'm sorry councillor williams but you
need to be okay right thank you it was
deferred last time on the grounds of
having a construction management plan
the applicants have gone away and have
done this and to me it's
it's it's fine in as much
as far as it goes perhaps the hours
could be changed um but to keep on
moving the goalposts every time it comes
before the community does seem a little
silly to me and unnecessary
um i can't accept i personally can't
support the refusal on these grounds
thank you
can we actually officers can we actually
um change uh put a condition in that the
hours are changed
that uh are more reasonable for the
school children coming along there
because it is a quite it's a very
dangerous road to walk along there if
you've got
construction uh what uh vans lorries
etc can we put as council asparagus said
can we actually uh put conditioning to
reduce the times
short answer short answer chairman is
yes because you're making it in but the
danger you have
is that
you're
dealing with
matters
that are straying into
other legislation territory that's not
planning the point was raised early
about how the site is going to be served
by pumping concrete you know they're not
reasons for refusal we've gone on to the
design issue and members are quite
within their remit to come to comment on
that but members are familiar that
there's been
in the attempt to address
certain conflicts the bulwark hall site
had a problem with the narrowness of the
access and the entrance onto the main
road and the concern for members at that
time was the
flow of traffic on the highway rather
than the specific danger that members
are worried about in in this case with
the pavement beneath the site as it were
and members chose
to uh restrict the hours and i've quoted
the the same condition that we did to
help to help members
and that developer as members have said
didn't challenge that
so that that's fine the problem you have
and where we have to advise you is if
the developer were to to take the matter
to appeal
and you're then trying to justify it now
your hearts might be in the right place
trying to do to do good and as members
have said it's not about mitigating like
the other agencies do the problem has to
occur and then they do something about
it it's trying to avoid
the problem in the first place and in
may the duty of care issue that members
have um was raised but
as officers we have to be careful that
we
don't encourage you as it were to stray
into territory that's other people's
remits that the planning decision
is essentially on the sort of the
permanence and the design of the
buildings and its degree of fit yeah we
spoke about whether the dormers are
appropriate
the previous schemes i think were
refused because of lack of car parking
the applicants taken units out and put
car parking into the site
so
the applicant is trying to meet the
physical planning considerations
if if members were wishing to control
that if you like to have site deliveries
that avoided the peak school times when
children would be expected on on the
pavement
like we did at bullwood hall you have
precedence for adopting that condition
if the applicant is unhappy with that
condition he could go to appeal i
wouldn't
want to forecast or predict any chances
on the success of that that's just
something we'd have to deal with
i think we've strayed away from the idea
of all the construction difficulties
this is a difficult site to develop
because it's constrained it's a small
site in a busy area but many of those
issues that are being raised aren't
anything to do with with planning
so yes to answer your question chairman
we could
adopt a condition and make it part of
the consent if members are so minded
to focus the delivery hours outside of
school times we we did that with
bullwood hall hopefully that's have
helped
right members we've got emotion on the
table it's been seconded for refusal can
i please have a show of hands
for voting for
refusal please
please counselor mrs mason
it's
basically the balkan mass is over
dominant in the area on the street
scheme the height in particular
causes concern the lack of
slope of pitch dormers
contrary to our policy and our policy
states quite clearly that um we should
have a good design that fits in with the
and a good standing and
it's not a bad design but i don't think
it's a good design in that location and
i think it's contrary to dm1 and cp1
in my view and it's the over dominance
and the visual immunity
are you okay with that cancer stone it
right can we go to the vote
for
refusal okay can i have a show of hands
please
keep them until sonia does
okay
against refusal
any abstentions
one abstention
right it's a it's four against four
four
one abstention and i've got the casting
vote so i'm voting
against refusal
yes council williams
thank you chairman therefore i'd like to
propose that we accept this
this uh
application with the amended times that
during school times
the the the
delivery is restricted and only during
school times
[Music]
what times are you i don't know the
times of the school i'm sorry
it's um early isn't it
here if this will helped um
just find
it greenswood school starts at 8 25
and
leaves at 14 55
plum row opens at 8 30 closes at 15 15.
the recommendation here is that
the
no deliveries start before 0 900 and
that there are no later deliveries than
14 30.
right members can we have that as a
condition please
so it's nine
fourteen council bearing was that nine
or nine thirty
900 thank you
and 14 30. i'm 14 30. thank you
so we've got a motion for
acceptance a seconder and we'll debate
that yes councillor fd i'd just say
can you actually speak in the mic please
it might be easier for the officers
safe
was it 14
30 14 30 for an hour
because then you've got after the school
time which might be easier
would that be helpful
chairman the
the bullwood hall one if that's what
members were
thinking of
now we're talking about fitzweinmark
it's where we had the um that was the
school where we had
we
restricted the hours not forward
sorry
i'm not familiar with that one so i'll
duck out
yeah so we did do restricted hours on
that
nine o'clock to 14 30.
the school
no
yeah
for the children to go in and out with
construction
right have we got anyone who wants to
debate this please or shall i go
straight to the vote for
accepting
of the recommendation
yes
can you speak to the mike please
that's it
yeah it works
we've done
we can't constrain them that far we have
we are actually constraining them i
my personal opinion we're constraining
them quite a bit on this i don't think
we can then say oh you can't have
between
whatever time the kids go out
for lunch i haven't got a clue because
you've got two schools two different
times then you're literally cutting the
this is only my opinion you're only
you're cutting the um developers time
construction people's time
down and obviously
for all of us if this is approved we
want it done
out and finished so it's so much less
disruption on that road
so can i have
a show of hands for
recommendation for approval of this
development please
any if we're against
abstain
sorry i want to make you guys
five four
two against two
three there's three three abstentions
those three abstentions that motion is
carried thank you members
we'll go on to item seven
agenda item 7 the dell stable block
madrid avenue ready and katie fowler
will present the officers report thank
you katie thank you chairman sorry i
just moved the mic a bit closer
right
thanks
the application site is located on
madrid avenue which is a private street
of rorth lane the road serves two
bungalows and a stable block which you
can see
on the location land here these are the
bungalows at the back and this is the
stable block subject to the application
the application building comprises two
groups of stables which once served the
equestrian use of the application site
the application site is located opposite
to the strategic development development
site on land north of london road the
area joining maintains an appearance
which is distinctively open the plot is
bordered by undeveloped agricultural
fields which contribute to the overall
sense of openness
and you can see here the open field and
then it's not on the location plan but
this is land north of london road just
off of it
plan permission is sought for the
demolition of the existing stable block
and the construction of one new dwelling
the proposed dwelling would be
constructed in a barn style comprising a
main building with a pitch roof and two
further pitched roof projections
following a similar footprint to the
existing stable block
paragraph 149 of the mppf outlines a
number of exceptions in which
development in the green belt is
considered appropriate part g of
paragraph 149 permits development of
previously developed land within the
greenbelt the current outbuildings were
last used for equestrian purposes and as
a result do not fall under the
traditional use of an agricultural
building this is because horses kept for
recreation sport and business and not
classed as an agricultural activity the
principle of the development is
therefore not considered to constitute
inappropriate development as it would be
considered as pdl
the existing floor space measures 202
meters squared the proposed development
would increase the floor space to
265.84 meters squared whilst this would
undoubtedly have a greater spatial
impact upon the openness of the
greenbelt the previous approved screen
which permitted three bungalows on site
had a footprint of
263.37 metres squared and the minor
increase of footprint of the proposed
development would not be considered more
harmful
the existing stables vary in height
between 3 meters and 4.6 meters meaning
they are low-key and single-story i'll
just go back to their existing plan so
you can see
the height of these on this section here
and then
um the height of the building here on
this section
the proposed running would have a
maximum height of five meters with the
pitch roof projections measuring the
lower height of 4.4 meters which you can
see the change in height
here so this is the lower pitched roof
projections and then the main building
here
the ground would be dug out one meter
below the existing land level height
meaning that from the existing ground
level the development would be no
greater in height than the existing
stables
it is considered that the proposed
development would not have a greater
impact on the openness of the greenbelt
than the existing buildings and the
extant plan of mission for three
bungalows and could therefore be
considered as appropriate element in the
green belt under exception g of
paragraph 149
with regard to the other material
considerations the proposed change of
use of the garden would be considered
acceptable and proportionate to the
dwelling proposed conditions are
recommended to protect the appearance of
the countryside in association with the
residential use the dwelling would not
be considered to have an unreasonable
impact upon neighbouring occupiers
the site would provide sufficient on
street parking spaces and would not be
considered to impact upon highway safety
the bat survey declaration indicates
that is not likely to impact on bats or
their habitats present on the site the
application is recommended for approval
chairman subject to conditions set out
in the report
thank you very much
we have no um
speak we've got no speakers on this i'll
be saying no thank you and we've got no
visiting members the ball counsellors
are councillor jim cripps and councillor
christine i'll ask um councillor stanley
speak first you've got five minutes
thank you chairman
um
this development
it's already been noted that it
is against the green belt at the
allocations plan of 2014
in which you need special
permission planning permission
which
this isn't a special planning permission
application and there's nothing in that
in the
dm-14 green tourism
and equestrian facilities
it says
the provision of equestrian facilities
is a popular form of rural
disciplication
increasing demand for espresso and
equestrian facilities within the
district however reinforcements need to
ensure that the balanced approach
through weighing the need for adequate
recreational facilities for equestrian
activities against the protection of the
greenbelt countryside the wide range of
nature conservation interests throughout
the district equestrian development can
appear as creeping urbanism and i
believe that this is creeping urbanism
in as much as that
the development
as is pointed out by the officers has
already been has already started and it
seems to be creeping towards the
main artillery arterial road
in as much air is that the
although the
property will be
dug out by one meter
where is that
i consider that the drainage would be
inadequate as well
for that area
as it would envelop the whole building
um there has to be some sort of drainage
being put in which hasn't been brought
forward to what to my knowledge anyway
and it's also
dm 27 where
they they haven't decided on protected
species
of the area and this is contrary to that
dm-27
so i would ask the committee to consider
rejecting this application refusing this
application on those grounds
thank you thank you councillor grips
no
members
have we
uh can't stop mrs mason
thank you jeff first of all could i ask
a couple of questions of the officers
and i was interested to read in the
report i think it's here that um
the existing um permission was for 202
200 square meters but they've actually
built it up to two
i've lost it to 63
and they're applying for 265 which is
roughly a third
increase on the original development
commission
[Music]
i think i have some sort of concern here
that effectively we're approving
something that shouldn't have been
approved it wasn't approved in the first
place the other concern i have is the
height
the report says quite clearly that it's
five meters high but one meter will be
underground
leading to roughly a four meter height
at visually visual height
but the
it also states that it's only the
majority of is three meters so it will
still be more dominant than the existing
building unless i've misunderstood that
so
i'd like some clarity on that point
please first
cody would you like to come back
stan counselor stanley's question both
of them yeah is that okay yeah please um
so i'll go to counselor stanley first
just so then we've got it in order so um
you first said about a country to add
the allocation plan the allocation plan
does allocate it as metropolitan
greenbelt but that doesn't mean that all
development is inappropriate so the mppf
outlines that there is some development
which is appropriate and development on
previously developed land is one of
those exceptions which is appropriate in
the green belt
you then discussed about policy dm14 but
this is in relation to green tourism not
a question
the
parts that you read out regarding to the
question is the preamble to the question
facilities so as in the construction of
new stables as opposed to the loss of
stables
and the drainage issue
there is actually part of the site has
been converted to a residential property
at some point so there is drainage on
the site as well as the bungalows to the
rear so
although it wouldn't be a main sewer
there is a an existing drainage on the
site
and
they would require an ea permit to
connect up to that possibility possibly
but it's not our legislation to cover
that
in relation to dm-27 the ecology they
have submitted a bat survey and it's
concluded that it's unlikely that it
would have an impact upon bats there's
not been the presence of them on the
site and it's not considered that there
would be likely any habitats or
protected species on the site because of
its state status at the moment outside
of the site there's actually a main arch
and things it's not um
overgrown grassland or hedgerows where
you would expect to see protected
species um so that's why we haven't saw
a ecological survey in this instance and
if i just move to councillor mason's
questions so
um the existing permission if i just
get my notes up
so
the existing floor space measures 202
meters squared
and then the proposed development is
265.84
but what has been permitted on the site
so that was it was replicating the
stables as they were but connecting them
up so they would kind of form a three
terraced bungalow in a way um and that
permitted then a floor space of 263
263.37 meters squared so there was a
marginal increase in
floor space so whilst it does look
dramatic going from the existing floor
space of 202 to 265.84 there is this
fullback position which means that there
is a is um something that's permitted on
the site with a with a larger footprint
than what is there at this moment in
time
um in regard to the height if i just
pull up the
sections
so
uh
so
if i just zoom in down here
and so you can see here this is the can
you see that okay was it a bit faint
zoom in a bit more
i'll try and get
there we go so
um this line here is dotted out where it
would be dug down to
so at the moment you can see it's this
main block here which um
it measures 4.75
eight meters and then the lower block
here measures some three something
meters can't remember the exact amount
and it's not put on but um from the
ground level it's actually four five
point seven because as you can see the
ground level raises up by over a meter
in total so
from the lowest level the maximum height
is 5.7
whereas on the proposed plan
they have only
they have got a maximum height of
5.5 meters at only one section so
actually they've
reduced it by 0.7 meters from where it
would be dug out so the lower land level
which is down here
so they've put on here the 3.4 where
the land level is here so you can see
that there
um
i don't know if that hopefully explains
it but essentially what they're doing is
digging it out by a meter and reducing
it in terms of the maximum height so
that there is kind of a balance so it's
offset from each other so where
there is a slight increase
overall
in terms of the bulk it is less than
what is actually there on site in one
place
um can i that's very clear
it's a muddy thing to read as well um if
i can ask a couple more questions i
think the the other concern i have
certainly alleviated that one the other
concern i have is the garden sizes out
of all proportion to the
size of the dwelling
and i can see the reason why because of
the access
but the comments in there that the
residential garden isn't and doesn't
have much impact on green belt well
there's a totally different type of
vegetation and layout
so
i wondered if there's two things we
could do is is can we keep
the majority of the garden area as green
belt so it doesn't become residential
and also bearing in mind
the dominance of that building and the
openness of it in the countryside would
it be possible if we would if the
committee was so decided to approve this
application would it be possible to
remove committed development rights
so that
we don't end up with other buildings
outside
if it should be
approved i've not seen any very special
circumstances but i set the point of the
footprint thank you
um thank you chad so the garden size if
i just go over to the location plan
um previously the application had
actually been submitted previously but
we refused it on uh greenbelt and design
grounds beforehand and um sorry the
garden area also
and as you can see there is a generous
site a generous area to the site leading
up to the road so before they hadn't
outlined where the garden area would be
so that was why it formed a previous
reason for refusal
but this time they've indicated that
they would like this hatched area as
part of the garden
i also agree that you don't really want
the garden area to sprawl over into the
it would all remain green belt it's not
going to be that but it's the change of
use to residential so it means that they
can have residential occupation of it
but we wouldn't want it to sprawl over
into this entire land so that you see
kind of residential paraphernalia over
the whole thing so and that's why we've
asked for it to be
uh contained they
are there are conditions attached so
there's condition four which relates to
landscaping plan and that's requiring
details of the boundary treatments i
think i've suggested in it that um it
should be paddock fencing so that you
don't get big close boarded fencing and
that again detracts from the cap to the
green belt whereas paddock fencing you
would more traditionally see within the
green belt as that's more associated
with rural activities
um then we've got condition five which
relates to removing permitted
development rights to do with fencing
and gates so they don't subdivide the
plot or can try and move the gates or
construct new ones fences rather because
giant new ones where we're obviously
seeking to
try and maintain the open character as
much as possible
and then condition six also seeks to
remove
permitted rights relating to
outbuildings because of the proximity of
the dwelling there is a limited scope of
how much development rights they would
have anyway because where the front
elevations are here you would only be
able to kind of extend here and then
when it where it um has a highway
frontage as well there is very limited
scope of actually what they would be
able to do under permitted development
but we have removed that um so that if
it avoids any construction of additional
our buildings
have been removed so
outbuild conditions
our buildings have been removed by
condition six gates and fences by
condition five and then condition seven
has removed extensions and alterations
to elevations on the roof meaning that
they can't build dormers can't convert
the loft space and oh sorry not
comfortable space they can't build
dormers but they would be able to put
roof lights in that hasn't removed that
but they wouldn't be able to extend
through rear extensions or side
extensions thank you one other question
if you bear with me um relating to the
the fencing which i quite agree with
is there any way that we can condition
on the type of boundary plants not being
too high because
i'd hate to see a row of conifers up
there
um so condition four requires details of
the planting that is proposed so we can
agree those details in accordance we can
if you think it's pertinent to the
application we could put on a condition
um
but we've got lunch yeah we have got a
landscaping plan but in it we
it says what plants have to be they have
to detail what plants are going to be
um planted on the site
so we have control over that anyway
that's in condition four yeah condition
four
yeah read it i don't think i've got the
condition
it's it's um 7.1
13 that's the page number oh yes i
defended one i don't think i read the
conditions to be honest i'll just assume
they were a standard you've got one to
seven conditions which i think
hopefully has helped uh answered your
questions actually
okay oh yes yeah
is there any other members ask them very
well thank you thank you thank you
officers anyone else would like to make
things right now
i'd like to put this uh emotions uh
through the chair um and we can have a
second for approval please that's
counselor afd for second
members can i have a show of hands for
this application
members against
and no abstentions i don't think so
so
eight four
i'm glad you're doing the my test
tonight and two against thank you that
motion has that has been carried this
application thank you it's been approved
item 8
7.2 sorry sorry
that's not a problem
and then we'll go on to our gender item
we're back
all back thank you
agenda item seven stroke two land north
of uh 172 rorith lane
katie again will uh present this thank
you katie
there we go thank you
um so the application site is located at
the end of cheshire drive which is
accessed by rorth lane and i've pulled
up an aerial image so that we can get
context a little bit better for this one
so
this is the application site here where
you see this kind of brown square
this is chesh hunt drive here and then
aurora's lime levorath lane projecting
along here we've got the asda car park
trenders avenue which is quite a popular
development site and then madrid avenue
that we've just seen is just further
down here and so
the cheshire drive is an unmade road
which serves plot uh serves plots of
land the site is north of the rear
gardens of the dwellings located on
royal lane and is separated by
underdeveloped land covered in
vegetation the site is completely
bounded by a closed board defense and
the existing planning use is unknown so
you can see the
trees and undeveloped character of
the uh the adjacent sites and the rear
boundaries of the gardens along royal
lane along here
planning permission is sought for the
proposed use of land for a gypsy
traveler pitch comprising one mobile
home one touring caravan and the
erection of a day room and stables if i
just go oh not that
this is the plan submitted for the day
room so you can see you've got a kitchen
and bathroom and then the stable
here and so you've got the tack room
loose box and then hay feed store there
an area of hard steeling would be laid
to accommodate for the proposed use and
a paddock fence and gate erected along
the eastern boundary fronting onto
cheshon drive the proposed occupants for
the site would be the applicant his
partner and their two children who are
both under age and both aged under five
whilst it has been stated by the agent
that the applicant has had to move on to
the site it is not clear in what
capacity this has taken place
the planning policy for travellers sites
to find gypsies and travelers as persons
of nomadic habit of life whatever their
race or origin including such persons
who on grounds only of their own or
their families or dependents educational
health needs or old age have ceased to
travel temporarily by excluding members
of an organized group of travelling show
people or circus people traveling
together as such
the applicant has stated they have spent
their life travelling and still travel
for three months of the year and attend
various cultural events throughout these
months
the applicant may cease to travel due to
prioritizing his family's educational
and health needs
on a balance of probabilities the
applicant has been considered to meet
the definitions set out in the ppts
the principal considerations of the
application is the impact of the
development upon the green belt the
policies relating to this are laid out
within the officer's report
with the exception of the existing
closed board defense the proposal would
otherwise introduce development on what
was essentially an undeveloped field
the proposal for residential development
would be considered to constitute urban
sport within the green belt equating to
inappropriate development that is
harmful by definition the development
must therefore demonstrate that there
are very special circumstances which out
the way outweigh the harm to the green
belt
so moving on to the very special
circumstances policy h7 of the core
strategy sought to allocate 15 pitches
by 2018 and this was
reflected through the allocation of gt1
at michelin's farm due to various
complications and difficulties
development of this site is yet to
commence and the council have not
exercised its power to compulsory
purchase
there are no other available allocated
or public sites available for occupation
within the district and therefore the
council's requirement to deliver gypsy
and travel pitches must be accommodated
elsewhere
further to this the latest formal
assessment of the district's need
identified the need of up to 18
additional pitches for households
meeting
the ppts definition of a traveller with
a further three pitches for households
where it is unknown whether the
definition is met
there has been the recent granting of
planning permission for four pitches and
therefore there remains a need for at
least 14 pitches dedicated to households
meeting the ppts definition as such the
council are unable to demonstrate a
five-year supply of sites for gypsy and
travellers and this should be given
significant weight in the greenbelt
balance in addition the lack of
alternative provision should also be
attached to significant weight
the applicant's family include two
children under the age of five and it is
important to the applicant for them to
obtain a good education a permanent
address is regis is required to register
the children to a school and prevent
disruption to their education the
application site will provide stability
and enable and enable consistent access
to medical
and educational services notably for the
children
the applicant has stated that if the
application refused is likely that they
would be forced to travel continually on
the roadside and double on other friends
and family member members pitches
this is supported by the lack of
alternative available and affordable
sites as such any alternative would not
be in the best interest of the children
and this would weigh significantly in
favor of the development
therefore while substantial weight is
given to the harm to the green belt
significant weight is also attached to
the need for gypsy and traveler sites
the lack of supply sites particularly
the uncertainty in bringing forward the
only allocated site the absence of local
policy and the lack of available
alternative accommodation for the
applicant and his family with
accessibility to health and education
services
in this case there are a number of
matters which are considered to weigh
significantly in favor of the
application and this conclusion would be
consistent with the outcome of recent
appeal decisions subsequently the
cumulative weight of these very special
circumstances would clearly outweigh the
substantial harm arising from
inappropriate development in the green
belt
in terms of the impact of the
development upon other considerations
there have been no reports of the
residential development causing noise or
disturbance and it is considered that
the impact of a single family would not
be unreasonable to neighboring occupiers
and as noted at the beginning it is
understood that they have moved on to
the site already and there hasn't been
reports of disturbance in the planning
application process
the site would be accessed through an
existing access on rort lane and would
not cause conflict with highway safety
the proposal involves the construction
of foul drainage a soak rate and
treatment plant the development of this
scale would not warrant significant
consideration of the foul drainage
proposed but an ea permit is likely to
be required and this is covered by
separate legislation
there are a number of trees within close
proximity to the application site and
the council's arborio cultural officer
has recommended a condition requiring a
method statement and protection plan
which has been imposed by condition
the application is recommended for
approval chairman subject to the
conditions set out in the report
thank you very much
now we have uh two local wall
councillors uh councillor crips and
council stanley councillor crips have
you anything to say please oh would you
like to say anything
yes i would like to say a few words
please you again we were like before you
got five minutes but that's fine
can you hear me on there
can you hear it can you hear councillor
crip's okay yeah
okay
thank you yeah item 45 on the officers
report foul drainage
um
and that diagram up there
apparently foul drainage is going to be
done via a soakaway
i've had a look at the essex county
council flood and water management
papers and it shows that area
as liable to flooding in all shades of
blue light blue medium blue and dark
blue
are you happy that this soak away in
that situation
is acceptable
have you a couple of questions or do you
want them
i'll say otherwise we'll get into is
that it thank you
and so the foul drainage proposed is the
treatment plant as opposed to the soak
away being used for found drainage
it says soak away in your 45
yes so it's part of the drainage on the
on the site but the treatment plant is
what would
take away the foul drainage okay so it's
not going to that corner then
i
wouldn't be able to advise on that of
where it would go from there well on
your drawing there there appears to be a
dotted line through to the corner i
would imagine that's a soap away
yeah that so that's labeled as the
circle that's just for general ground
water is it
we don't get those details as part of
the application so as part of the
planning process we don't wouldn't need
to consider that level of detail at this
point in the application
we would need we just need detail of
what they would be proposing and that's
what we've got my concern is uh there's
a lot of weight added to the best
interest of the children in your
write-up
and my my concern was that soak away
which is what it says here
for the foul
water
is
in that corner and if that floods
you're going to get far away squashed
across the site and you've got
the waiting for the best interest of
children i don't think that's in the
best interest of children that's why i
wanted to clarify
whether that aspect has been considered
because in your report there is no
reference to
flood risk
yeah so there isn't flood risk on the
site it's not subject to
fluvial flooding or surface water
flooding so there isn't a concern from
that aspect if
for a different matter the soak way did
flood that wouldn't be covered by
planning legislation it would be a
concern of a different legislation
probably the environment agency
okay but the reference i gave you the
essex flood and water management scheme
acc
their map shows it very clearly subject
to potentially subject to flooding
for various types light blue medium blue
and dark blue in that area
so we have to go against the flood maps
that we get presented by
the environment agency and this site
isn't subject to
surface water or fluvial flood risk as
identified by the ea
okay
i'm still concerned about the children
in that situation but okay you've
answered my question
thank you council stanley
thank you chairman um
just to
elaborate a little bit on on the flood
risk there um there is a
uh the
roy stream which runs through that
property on that corner where that
cesspit is or whatever you
soak away
the water actually runs into that pond
there is another pond
further to the left of that drawing
which is not uh put on there but there
are two ponds which actually fill up on
flood risk
um
chestnut drive doesn't stop where you
where it says on the map it actually
goes right to the end which picks up a
crossroad between trenders and
parkhurst
so it doesn't stop there land the land
further on is owned by other people and
they need to use this land this drive to
get to their property which is their
portion of lands which they have been
allocated furthermore
um
i still uh i i still
would like to emphasize that there are
no special circumstances
um
for this
this development on metropolitan green
belt
um the
i need to be
absolutely sure that the appropriate
meaning of gypsy and traveler
is is the correct one
as further on from that development
to the end of chesan drive
the
applicant has
basically
put fencing up and gates up to stop the
road being used completely right the way
through
um there he has got um
a caravan
and other machinery that has application
to his business i suspect
[Music]
again i don't see that we
we have done anything with the
ecological
protected of species in that area
it is vastly overgrown
and
there is no no there's no no reference
to that at all
um and i think that this should be
looked into as
as much as the drainage
i don't want because of the river
running through the back of that
it also runs down to the fish farm at
shakespeare drive
that water if it's contaminated will
wipe out
that fishery
completely
we've already had problems i've got
problems at the moment and ea know about
this on the river roach
where the fish have been content where
the water's been contaminated and the
fish are actually lying on the top dead
so i'm particularly worried about that
and i've been in touch with the ea
on
that particular thing which says advice
for local authorities on non-mains
drainage and the reason that they can't
get mains drainage is that they are
under 30 meters
under 30 meters from the drain
so they can't get mains drainage if they
was above 30 meters they could get it
and it would be it would be put into
chess and drive but unfortunately
they're not
uh so they don't can't apply for that
but it does say and i've already spoken
to you you're not gonna read all that
out no you've got no copy for everyone
no i'm not going to read it all that
there's nine pages here i'm certainly
not going to read their nine pages
it does say that we
as statuto the environment agency is no
longer a strategy consultee
on this sort of development in the way
of drainage and it asks or it says the
change means it is local planning
authority
responsibility to ensure proposals for
non-mains drainage or non-major
development complies with the national
planning policy framework and planning
practice guide and i don't believe
this is my own personal opinion i don't
believe that that drainage is adequate i
know they will need permit
to operate it but i don't believe that
that
that's sewage plant which is going to be
installed is not correct and not in the
right place so therefore i would ask a
motion of refusal to this site or to
defer it
to this to discover
what they're putting in there
and whether it is in the right place or
not
thank you
i've got
oh wait a minute i've got a promotion
scientific can i know what what did you
want a motion to defer or refuse
you first no you've got you've got one
or the other oh okay
deferred in right have you got a second
second
right
i've got i'm having people wave at me
because we can't do um
because of me i can't
get close to people even please just
like
yeah yeah of course um so firstly on the
i'm gonna come to the water and the
drainage points last if that's okay so
um the gypsy and traveller definition
the applicant submitted a personal
statement with the application which is
private and confidential because of the
nature of the application
officers consider that the information
submitted which discusses their um the
fact that they've traveled all their
life um the fact that they still travel
three months of the year and they want
to settle because of their educational
and health needs of the child of the
children and that they do meet the gypsy
and traveler definition we haven't had
any evidence presented to us to say on
the contrary and therefore on the
balance of probabilities
there we would have to say that they are
of gypsy and traveller status
um
i know that you've considered that there
aren't very special circumstances but we
would consider that
there are in this case because of the
fact that we can't demonstrate and our
five-year supply the allocated site
isn't being brought forward at present
um there are no reasonable available
alternative sites and the very special
circumstance very personal circumstances
of the applicant and the needs of his
children and then i just would like to
touch on the drainage so
we can see that they've put forward a
treatment plant so they specified that
it would be something like a biodigester
t6
an on-site file connection so if we've
looked at so the ea guidance says that
in the mppf and mppg it says it's to the
local planning authority to consider in
both of those frameworks and the
guidance it doesn't say specifically
uh what role we have to play in that it
doesn't the mppf doesn't talk about
wastewater at all and the mppg um
doesn't specify anything for mine in a
development such as this so we've looked
at um further guidance and if i just
brought on the screen so this is a
package treatment plant or septic tank
advice provided by the environment
agency so
if we look at the first point it says in
the is this site within an area where
the environment agency locally has ident
um is indicated the planning authority
that specific safeguards are necessary
for discharges to ground or surface
water in this case it's a no so we move
on to this one does the main system
involve a discharge solely to
watercourse no
assess appropriateness of foul drainage
discharge to the ground as proposed
using flow water part 2a below does flow
of char part 2a indicate that norm mains
foul drainage as proposed may not be
appropriate or that permanent permit
upland application should be twin
tracked we haven't had indication of
this so we would say no
does the results from the fda indicate
any of the following the system is less
than seven metres away from any
habitable part of a building no
vehicular access for emptying within 30
meters system cannot be emptied or
maintained without the contents of being
taken through a dwelling or place of
work the answer to this one is no also
has the applicant provided details of
how they propose to maintain the system
this is also no so the ea advised that
we either ask for further information or
secure maintenance through the condition
so in this instance we would recommend
to members to put forward a condition to
secure main uh secure maintenance plan
for the foul drainage
thank you chair would you like to come
back and i've got other members uh
councillor stanley would like to speak
on this
i'll let the others speak and they'll
come back last if i
um
i questioned ms fowler's comments about
uh we do not have five-year supply
of sites available
many years ago
michelin's farm by a planning inspector
was advised that it was totally unusable
that it would never be suitable for a
gypsy and travellers site as indicated
and it certainly wouldn't be useful as
an industrial site
we now have a very large industrial site
and down at fairglenn interchange on
michigan's farm
so that argument is out of the window
as i understand it
any other issues that ever raised the
planning inspectors have refused to go
down
and reassess what was previously said
many years ago the fact that there is
ongoing conversations which i'm sure
most people are aware of that now we've
got an industrialist day down there
that there is still
conversation going on about the gypsy
and travellers site i cannot accept your
assessment that we do not have a
five-year supply of gypsy and travellers
site if it goes forward which i don't
see why ultimately it shouldn't there
would be 15 sites there as i recall
going from memory thank you chairman
thank you cuts mr payson
thank you chair
just a couple of small points really
one
i think the application from what i've
heard should have been addressed as
retrospective
two and perhaps the officer can clarify
this for me
um item 17 it says no details have been
submitted relating to the appearance of
the mobile home or touring caravan
which
i have enough but then in the in the
condition four we've got
comprising no more than one static
caravan and one touring caravan
there's a significant difference between
a static caravan and a mobile home
so
i'm a little bit concerned that we're
not asking for details and what are we
approving is it a mobile home or is it a
static caravan
um so they're proposing a mobile home
and a touring caravan
so the mobile home it might be i'm not
sure and i haven't looked at the report
exactly it might be that i've misspoken
one of them but it is a mobile home that
they've put forward so
that is both a touring caravan and a
mobile home are of a touring car
but you put one static caravan and one
touring caravan that may be a misspoke
but they have referenced it as a mobile
home and i think we ought to
request some details of the static
caravan stroke mobile home because they
are significantly
variable and i think that's something
that we ought to consider
that's just a small point
but the
other point um
condition i've lost it
condition two
this is assuming approval of course
that
the use hereby permitted should be
carried out only by mr charlie eastwood
and his resident dependents
now
i've heard you say that it's his partner
and two children
i do think that in the
spirit of equality and for future
proofing the security of the children
that the partners should be named on
this as well
so that it could be for
mr
charlie eastwood and xxx i don't know
his partner's name um because i do think
that's quite important because we're
talking about a family unit and families
do break up so
from that point of view i'd like to if
it's appropriate i'd like to see both
names on there
and apart from that i can understand the
concerns raised but
regarding the foul series but i think it
should be done by
condition
because
partly because the failure of the reason
we have these applications is because
the failure of the council to provide
permanent site we haven't done so
thank you thank you council reeves
of the addendum that we've got as well i
think it would be remiss of us not to
actually consider
what the
neighbor has actually asked there
for the wording of the site proposal um
to state that it accesses all plots
along its length not just the
applicant's site
as has been mentioned it appears as
though the fencing that has been put up
at the moment is preventing
uh access further down the uh down the
road i'm not sure if that is the case
but if the officers can confirm that but
i think it would be um
uh
remiss of us not to consider
the um the addendum that has been
presented on item
72.
thank you
could you answer that
basically yeah thank you i'll go through
um everything that was read so in regard
to the five-year supply
we as development management officers
can't put forward an application for
michelin's and at the moment it hasn't
been delivered and there isn't
uh
it isn't evident that it is going to be
delivered at present to us so we have to
take account there hasn't that the
five-year supply hasn't been met and
because we can't demonstrate that at the
moment it is going to be until it would
there was a
compulsory purchase put forward we
wouldn't be able to take that into
account
um
so then in regard to
condition two and um so the partner has
been asked to be
kept private their name that's why it
hasn't been put on um but we could add
something to do with the
mr charlie eastwood and their civil
partner um so to avoid revealing their
identity
um and then in regard to the preventive
access
it isn't part of the application for
those gates um it would be a separate
matter either planning
uh planning breach or it would be a
private civil matter depending on who
owns the road
and what what breaches has occurred but
um it isn't part of the application so
it wouldn't be something that we would
be able to reasonably
prevent
so
sorry
yeah
um am i right in what i'm hearing that
the applicant has actually blocked the
road
by the fencing
i
know that offense has been erected but i
wouldn't be able to say it's the
applicant
would the ward members be able to
confirm that
sorry councilor stanley wants to come
back so okay yep we can't be confirmed
you've asked the question
do you know it for fact council in fact
yes uh double gates have been put at the
not where the green circles start on
that
drive but at where it says track at the
end of track that's where the double
gate has been put
sorry can i just make sure that i know
what i'm talking about so where the
hatching of the fencing is the black
little lines where it says track but
you've got a gate there yes they most
certainly have and they're they're using
what's laid out there is the east
boundary that is the the boundary that
runs down chess and drive
as their plot of land and he's
designated the west boundary which is on
the pond side as his pot of plot of land
and i would like that as a condition to
make sure that his plot of land is on
the east side and not on the west of
that road right you have put a motion up
but i've got a motion up can i just
speak to the reference of the gypsy and
travellers site please well no because
we've now got the motion up for deferral
so we need to now know
why
so the officers can actually fight we
can we've got a vote on it obviously a
minute but they will need to have
clarity
of why what the motion is of why you
want it deferred please
right can i just point out that the
chest drive does show on the map to go
continue on
uh as i've said um yeah i've forgotten
what i was because i mean i've got away
with
before you start sorry councillor the
officers would like to come back
sorry officers would like to come back
first before you speak
sorry about that sorry i just wanted to
karaoke yes so i just want to clarify
that the red line here so that the kind
of square that we identified at the
start is the subject of the application
so we wouldn't be able to condition or
restrict anything that was going on on a
site outside of that red line boundary
um and in terms of the the gate it isn't
i've been formed it's not planning
breach because of the height of it it's
a civil matter so again it's not
something that we can control within the
planning application
the size of the application by putting
those red lines around and that is the
condition that he's got to work to yeah
anything correct anything outside of
that would be a bridge of this planning
application if you were to develop any
part yeah understood right so you you've
put a deferral up can we have now what
why would you like this deferred what
other information you would like
um
no i'm going to keep it yeah if you put
up a deferral
referral you've had it seconded so we
need to know why
obviously
it's no good saying i'd like it deferred
so our officers then go run away that's
fine why is it deferred and what they
won't know what information you require
so now we need to know what information
you actually require
from our officers to get from the
applicant then it can come back if it is
deferred
right
that the deferral means that or is
asking for clarification on the sewage
treatment and
surface water treatment that's being
disposed of
in relation to the
project
on site
and you're happy with that to second
that counts to crips right officers
is that
we could deal with it by condition
instead so we request the details of
that by condition
so that could be done by a condition
subject to what
so it would be approved subject to
condition and then that condition be
would be added
but what is the condition going to say
yeah just just to confirm so um
the
application that the actual
applicant has submitted details of what
they're proposing to actually put on the
site for the foul water drainage
and we could then do
is ask them to provide us with
further detail to demonstrate how that
would work on the site as a condition
because they've actually they've
they've achieved what the environment
agency instruct us to do as a planning
authority to make sure that details have
been submitted to the authority of how
the surf how the foul water is going to
be dealt with and the surface and the
surface water that's what i'm concerned
with as well because we know
uh from
our concert our conversations with
neighbours that that area does flood and
you may not say it floods the
environment agency may not say it does
flood or not flood but we know and i
live just around the corner from here
that it does flood so i'm really really
concerned that with flooding and
effluent going into that river is going
to cause us
harm and i want to have reassurances
whether you put it in as a condition
or referral to get back to find out
exactly what they're doing so what we
could do is put a condition on for
further details to be submitted about
how the foul water drainage works and
then also details of how they would deal
with any surface water on the site thank
you very much well i'm just going to
have one more question from
jericho
i've got you know right in front of me
faces sorry
completely
i need it bigger
sorry
yeah please
sorry i do apologize just going to ask a
question because we seem to be rather
concerned about the
foul and surface water
and i hear the officers have said that
we've complied with the requirements of
the
um water authority
but
presumably that's a minimum requirement
there's no
harm in us making doubly sure but i
think you've answered the question by
saying we put it on as a condition so i
think they've clarified what i was
concerned about so thank you thank you
now uh councillor fd and then we're
going to go to a vote i'm a little bit
confused now you're going to ask if the
deferral needs to still be on the table
or are we going to go for a refusal
sorry
sorry
so now you've got the competition uh it
can be conditioned
i'll i'll accept the condition
with the officer's advice
and i'll take the motion away right
thank you very much are you okay with
that uh counselor thank you very much
that makes it
is everyone clear we're now gonna vote
the recommendation i'll do it from the
uh chair is for approval
so can i have a seconder please
we're sorry yes as
with the condition as we've discussed
and debated yeah thank you
can i have a second to please
right members the emotions on the table
for approval of this site uh
can i have a show of hands please
thank you against
three
and there's no extensions
so there's seven four approval three
against so that is carried thank you
members that is the end thank you very
much for a nice
good meeting and over the rest of a good
august for holidays if you're doing
i'm going to alaska
[Music]
you